[موسيقى]
القوميه مع الاسلام
ظاهر ثقافيه
الظاهره الثقافيه
مثل الظاهر على المناخيه تظهر لظروف
احيانا معرفه احيانا نعرف الظروف
وربما تعاود لكن تترك اثرها اما ان يكون
قويا كاسحا او انكم متوسطه
الظاهره تانها ثاني الثقافيهتان في القرن
العشرين
تحديدا وممتده الاسلاميه
ظهرت في العالم العربي
خلنا ركز على القوميه
القوميه العربيه ظهرت
دي فعلا على
القوميه التركيه لما تحولت الخلافه
العثمانيه
الدوله العثمانيه من الكون
نهائيا خلافه اسلاميه الى ان تصبح دوله
قوميه تركيه
قبل ان تسقط العثمانيه قبل لا تتركيا
[موسيقى]
اذا تتحول تركيا الفتاه فبدات تلغي المكون
العربي
لغه وارضا وانسانا وتقوم بتتريك كل ما هو
عربي ارضا ومنع تدريس اللغه العربيه حتى
منعت اللغه العربيه في المواطن العربيه
تحرك الشعور العربي
بحثا عن هويه لانه خلاص يعني ان يتحولوا
هم كجزء من خلاف اسلاميه مقبول ظل مقبول
يعني على توالي القرون ان يتحولوا الى
اتراك بمعنى انهم مستعمرون لغه وارضا
وتفكيرا هذا استلاب كامل هناك تتحرك
الهويات في كل مكان ترد فعل لاستعاده
هويتها
وتجزير هذه الهويه مقابل هذا الالغاء حاله
الغاء قويه قويه وجذريه
[موسيقى]